(clapping)
- Have y'all met before?
- Yes we have.
- Oh, you have?
- Yes, yes.
- We did. We did.
- Okay, awesome.
Awesome. I didn't know if
y'all, sometimes people haven't
and we like to bring people together, but
but we were talking about music.
So you play piano
right?
- I do, yes.
- Like since you were a kid, right?
Like little.
- Yeah, over 20 years now.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
I also have to say, you guys were so sweet
to me when I met you
guys, you they welcomed me
into their home and we did
this table reading there.
- Oh.
- You guys are adorable.
- Yeah, you were, was great.
- Great to have you.
- You guys were so nice.
I have to just quickly tell a story
which is that my dad called me yesterday
and I told him I was
coming out with you guys
and he insisted that I
attempt to tell some story
about him auditioning for Footloose.
And he like
- He didn't make the cut.
- He regaled me with this
like seven minute story
and was like, make sure you tell that.
I was like, so you want me to
use the entire time talking
about you?
- Use my entire segment?
- Yes.
- Your own segment.
- Completely about him.
- Oh, my god.
- And then at the very end was like
and make sure you say hi.
I was like, cool.
That's very fitting.
So
- I love your relationship with your dad.
Everybody, if you don't
know, obviously Rob Lowe
in the show.
So I love do you get to, do
you get to carry that out?
Like any kind of like
therapeutic things that you
actually had in life?
Do you get to carry that
out in any of these scenes?
Cause that scene was hilarious.
- It's wildly cathartic. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- cause we, we, I get to, first of all, I
I get to roast him on
national television, which is
- That's awesome.
- Every child's dream I think.
- Yeah.
- Especially when you have a,
a borderline narcissist parent.
- My God, I love your relationship.
- Yes. No, he's very, he's a great dad.
But you know,
we have an interesting relationship
and I would say that in the
show, it's very sweet too.
It's, it's, it's biting, but
it's sweet and we get these
these resolutions at
the end of the episode
and we hug and say, I love you.
And and that's where the
acting is and it's very...
Like what's
- I'm watching this show.
- Oh My God. That's amazing.
- I get that, that's the therapy for me.
- You're Hilarious.
So John, now you have this show
it's called Unstable, which
is the greatest title ever.
So it's it's with your father.
So what is it basically
about y'all's relationship?
- Yeah, it's it's based
on our relationship.
- Yeah.
- We, we don't play exactly ourselves.
He plays sort of an eccentric,
insane biotech engineer
entrepreneur, kind of Elon Musk-y vibes,
which uhh...
you know is ripe to make fun of, I think.
- Yeah.
- I love the the style of
like comedy of manners and,
- Yeah.
- Poking fun at the social elites, and
it's very relatable that dynamic
of a, a parent that's very
well annoying and
- Yeah. Yeah
- Oversteps boundaries.
- Yeah.
- But, but, but they're
intentions are pure
and they just care.
And our relationship
happens to be sort of unique
in that he's in the
public eye and so, and,
and, and "beloved".
And so, there's not that
many people that agree
with me when I say like, no,
but you don't understand.
He's, he, he can be wildly annoying.
- Yeah.
- So when you don't have many
people to turn about that.
- Every parent can. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I got a quick pitch for a storyline.
You find out that your dad,
who's the Elon Musk type.
- Yeah.
- Actually unbeknownst to
you, auditioned for Footloose.
- If you, Okay.
- And you get to point out the
fact that he didn't get it.
- He didn't get it.
He claims it's cause he like blew his knee
out in the audition, which
is the most Rob thing ever.
- He was going to be amazing.
- He'd be like, I was
crushing it until the minute.
I'm just picturing like,
he was seeing people not enjoying it
and he was like, my knee oh my god,
he is like, get the stretcher.
- My god, your level of
wit is incredible, Man.
- Aw, thank you.
- Oh my God, I love you.
I cannot wait for
everybody to see this show.
This show is incredible.
We need to take another break.
John's show Unstable is on Netflix.
Check it out if you wanna
have a really good time.